again a sex in marriage or relationship
and obligation
no you should enjoy it obligations every
time he wants to bend you over are you
letting him put it inside you is what
I'm saying oh if you're married for a
relationship no it's honestly guys about
feelings like it's about the Bible says
no and he seeks it elsewhere is that a
problem you're gonna say yes but see but
that's that's messed up so then because
you're because you're what I'm saying
I'm saying because you're just thinking
about what you want because you
in the context of marriage yes that's
correct you know context of a
relationship act cool just bounce so
when you're married what are your what
are your obligations from a man for you
in a relationship which century and what
do you what do you want from a man like
what is he obligated to for you in a
relationship well I'm saying loyalty is
not there trust loyalties up there
that's that's a must but then if you
guys are saying that no no for you yes
obligation from a man yes for you yeah
just those two things well that's one of
them I can't think and list them all up
but yeah the main one is loyalty and to
respect me love me all of that stuff
that's that's up there that's well what
if he says I'm only doing that for
someone that's my wife I'll respect you
but I'm out
you can't be loyal or respect me but you
want to be with me you only be
respectful and loyal to your wife
so then either you put a ring on this or
I'm gone that's it what if he said I'm
gone unless you give me sex on demand
I'm gone as well then you're gone
you don't think sex is a duty in
marriage but she just oh we took my
marriage all day and I'm confused like
you keep changing it it's marriage I'm
usually talking in the context of
marriage but I don't know
I'm not married I can't speak on
marriage I've never been married I mean
I I even think in a relationship
honestly if he's not sleeping with
anyone else yeah you should give him sex
whenever he wants whatever he wants yeah
guys want to [__] all the time so if I'm
saying like please don't [__] other
girls just [__] me like then I should I
should get back together
okay wait I understand that but then if
there's just a one day where it's like
I'm not in it right now or I'm on my or
whatever you're not obviously
does that mean that he now has a right
to go and have sex with someone
obviously it's not one day come let's be
let's be real by it like that's what I'm
saying but you guys are making it sound
I'll give you one day not two I'll give
you one day in that too
if you miss work one day they might give
you a passive two days in a row you
might you might be getting a pink slip
how is the scenario that you gave us
earlier about
um your your mess with your man yeah
yeah and work
feeling well
but they got all colors they will still
go to work
but if that man wants some sex they got
excuses for it they've got a headaches
but they've never got a headache to go
to work yeah
he's not giving you money yeah I mean
that's women
like we're saying that our man actually
is going to cheat or is cheating because
you didn't give it enough
at least your job's still there for when
you get back
at least they didn't fire you just to
tell them I just think that's the duty
to have sex with your man whenever he
wants it however you want yeah so what
about the opposition
if you want to have sex
guys guys before we go again and let's
just reiterate some rules I know we've
got some new people on the panel but
guys one at a time I cannot hear you
they can't hear you please let's do this
all right
as far as I'm concerned we may need to
free up all the time Andy what if you
want what if he's at work what should I
do to your workplace
what if we're at the grocery store oh
they got taught in ghosts
[Laughter]
what if we're at the library I don't
care
what if we're at a concert this is my
I'm taking it wherever wherever he wants
it I'm gonna be cooking I could be
washing that washing machine what if
you're on a podcast
yeah
it's only fans I'm getting paid for it
yeah I'll never go so I just think you
need to do it all the time I have a
question for you two ladies because when
Auntie's talking about that earlier she
was talking about it we were like yeah
if that's my man that's my husband why
wouldn't I you two right now your facial
expression your body language is
when she's talking about it it's like no
I wouldn't do that if he wants it I
wouldn't do that all the time if if no
but if if you want sex all the time
unless you're a man or whatever then
fair enough have six but the point I'm
trying to get at is you could be giving
him you could be firming it back do like
you could be giving it to him all day
every day he will still go somewhere
else see someone has the choice to cheat
she's dead and I'll still have sex with
her even though my girl is giving it to
me every day okay
no no but I'm saying so like can I just
I'll explain so life is about trade-offs
so you can either pick a guy that other
women want and know he might cheat on
you or you can pick a guy a guy that no
other women want and he won't cheat on
you but the thing is girls pick the guys
that other women want to bang he might
cheat but how would how would you know
you you know and the thing is like girls
act stupid like no that no I'm not I'm
not I'm not talking about you I'm not
talking about you girls will act stupid
like they don't know know this guy might
cheat like but they know they know what
like you you can feel it on a guy if he
gets a lot of girls honestly like if I
can't express my point of view I wasn't
like about uh the fact if I love that
man I will definitely uh sex with him
whenever he won't because I want it I
want it come on but if you action
[Laughter]
I'll be talking about like if2 that's
another point I don't have to I want it
it's different like in a marriage it's
supposed to be like that I have designed
I want you because I love you because
there's something between us not because
you asked me and that's one of my duty
which is different I don't have duty
even for one day I'm sick and like I
just add the baby let's say man like you
know I agree with you I agree with you
you know the problem is I think a lot of
women are quite idealistic about future
so a lot of women think about as I am
now in a relationship when you've been
there for 30 years your feelings and
emotions
if you and your woman having good sex
and she gets 20 years old or 30 years
older she said no I'm too old she's
talking rubbish Banger right
[Applause]
you know what makes me sick about some
women especially like West Indian women
when they get a house they will get the
priests to come around the bless you but
they don't want to go around and bless
every room with their mouth there is not
a room in my house that I haven't
performed in every house
because you know what I'm blessing the
house I can't sit down in that yeah
go for it and women does this get
support oh I'm getting too old rubbish
if your woman's getting too old God then
find somebody else that's young enough
for you I'm telling you go out there
because as far as I'm concerned leave
her ass
just lie down and as far as I'm
concerned if you've got the right man
and you're not in the mood right you
gotta he'll get you in the mood he will
get used
to grab this thing what do you mean come
here